le ministre investige fait valoir que
son gouvernement a été efficace et
prudent et c'est pourquoi dit-il la
province connaît un succès économique
mais malgré ce succès il ne délit que
légèrement les cordons de la bourse
voilà
il n'y a rien de nouveau pour la classe
moyenne dans ce budget explique-t-il et
le ministre ne prévoit pas de grandes
dépenses pour faire face à la crise du
logement non plus ceux qui s'attendaient
à ce que le gouvernement montre un peu
de compassion leur offre un peu d'aide
et qui eSport d'avoir des solutions pour
augmenter l'offre de logements ben ils
vont être déçus aujourd'hui on peut
sauver de l'argent si on l’investit
aujourd'hui dans le logement
rien fait un mystif préfère y aller
prudemment cette année encore en raison
de l'incertitude qui guette à l'horizon
dont un ralentissement économique il
prévoit que ces recettes vont diminuer
et Satan à un surplus budgétaire de 40
millions de dollars le ministre des
finances prévoit donc un modèle sur plus
budgétaire pour la nouvelle année
financière mais plusieurs croient déjà
que le portrait va changer d'ici la fin
de l'année c'est pas très réaliste et
puis je pense qu'on se prépare encore
une fois pour un surplus pharaonesque en
fin d'année Richard Saillan fait partie
des sceptiques il rappelle que le
gouvernement a terminé les deux
dernières années avec des surplus
beaucoup plus importants que prévu dans
celui de près de 900 millions de dollars
pour 2022 2023 alors qu'il prévoyait un
maigre sur plus de 35 millions
faire des prévisions c'est difficile
dans le contexte actuel marqué par
l'inflation et la pandémie du ministre
gouvernement sous-estime massivement ses
revenus pour l'année qui vient pour
éviter de mettre de l'argent dans les
salaires là où le gouvernement se montre
plus généreux par contre c'est pour le
recrutement et la rétention des
travailleurs de la santé ils prévoient
investir 30 millions de dollars mais
c'est bien insuffisant selon le syndicat
des infirmières qui jugent que la
Nouvelle-Écosse a un bien meilleur
programme comme un moment donné moi je
me ça fait pas dansant ce nouveau budget
lesbien des gens sur leur appétit ils
espèrent beaucoup plus alors que les
finances de la province se portent
particulièrement bien ici Michel Bridou
Radio-Canada Frédéric